Speaker 1: All right. Before we get to voicemails,
I want to tell you about something which it's one
of these things where, like it very clearly
seems like a lie, but if it were true,
it's almost even worse. There's a very interesting
Rolling Stone article which says that Trump told
his White House team that he needed to protect,
quote, Russiagate documents. Okay. So understand,
this is the assertion being made and we'll talk
about whether it's true. The former president
who left the White House with a trove of sensitive
material believes there are documents that would
expose a deep state plot against him and told
confidants he needed to protect them from the
next administration. So really, I mean, this
is crazy, but think about what it is that it is
being being asserted here in this Rolling Stone
article. In his final days at the White House,
Trump told advisers he needs to preserve certain
Russia related documents to keep his enemies
from destroying them. Ah, okay. The documents
relate to the federal investigation into Russia,
election meddling and alleged collusion with
Trump's campaign. At the end of his presidential
presidency, Trump and his team pushed to
declassify these so-called Russiagate documents,
believing they would expose a deep state plot
against him, according to a person with direct
knowledge of the situation and an. Another source
briefed on the matter. Trump told several people
working in and outside the White House he was
concerned that Biden's administration or the Deep
State would shred, bury or destroy the evidence
that Trump was wronged. This is a newly relevant
claim based on the FBI search. So let let's kind
of talk through this. Right. If it is true that
Donald Trump believed he had the steel documents
because they exposed the deep state plot against
him, which the Biden administration would shred
and destroy. That is bonkers nuts. But there's a
second layer to this stuff. Just because Trump
said that's what he believed doesn't mean it's
actually what he believed. And what I mean by that
is if these documents really exonerated Trump.
Why would he want to take them and hide
them? These would be things you would want
to publicize. And you can't rule out that this
is something that's being brought up now to try
to justify Donald Trump taking the documents
that he took. So so there's like three or four
different layers to this thing. But again,
if this was really what Trump said and what
Trump believed, he is essentially Cunanan.
Right. If the Republican Party essentially
elected Cunanan to the presidency when they
elected Donald Trump. But because it's Trump,
we never want to ignore the possibility that this
is only what some are claiming, Trump said, and he
didn't really say it. Third possibility that this
is something Trump said but didn't mean. There's
also you have to assume everybody might be lying.
The people now telling Rolling Stone, Trump said,
this might be lying. Trump might have said it, but
might have been dishonestly saying it to create
plausible deniability over saying taking the
documents. Anything is true. It's a stack of lies.
It's it's like those Russian matryoshka dolls
where you open the door and there's a smaller and
smaller doll in it. It's lies and deception and
lies and deception all big together. Almost like a
beef Wellington of sorts, I think maybe is the way
I would describe it. Really wacky, wacky stuff.